[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin c'est bonjour
monsieur bous merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous politologue fondateur et directeur
de l'Observatoire des pays arabes et
puis auteur de ce livre le tsunami arabe
c'est chez Faya on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice Vess don du
groupe ébra bonjour Fabrice bonjour
Orian bonjour Antoine Basbous bonjour
monsieur monsieur Basbous on va
évidemment parler de la situation en
Israël et à Gaza mais d'abord on avait
envie de vous entendre sur ce qui s'est
passé ce weekend et cette nouvelle
attaque terroriste qui a eu lieu samedi
soir à Paris la saillant qui a dit aux
policiers qu'il ne pouvait plus
supporter que les musulmans meurent tant
en Afghanistan qu'en Palestine il aurait
déclaré qu'il en voulait pour ce qu'il
se passait à Gaza et que la France
serait complice de ce que faisait Israël
là-bas alors c'est vrai que depuis le 7
octobre on parle beaucoup de
l'importation du conflit est-ce que là
on y est à vrai dire le terroriste en
question il n'a pas commencé saamue avec
Gaza ça fait 9 ans qu'il a qu'il est
actif qu'il a des réseaux complotistes
des réseaux terroristes il voulait
partir en Syrie bien avant Gaza il
voulait attaquer à la défense bref par
son réseau par ses actions par ses
intentions il avait été condamné même à
5 ans de prison bref ce n'est pas Gaza
qui est à l'origine même si ça peut
influencer un comportement d'autant plus
que l'intéressé a des troubles
psychiatriques et il avait arrêtter de
prendre ses médicaments étant donné que
la communauté internationale n'arrive
pas à retenir le bras d'Israël on va y
revenir est-ce qu'il est envisageable
que le Hamas tente d'exporter le conflit
notamment par le biais du
terrorisme aucune connexion n'a été
établie entre le Hamas et cet homme-là
cet homme a été radicalisé il y a 9 ans
avant que le le conflit actuel à Gaza ne
soit déclenché mais au-delà de ce cas
précis au-delà de ce cas précis
évidemment il peut y avoir des
sympathies de côté et d'autres entre des
gens qui applaudissent Israël et des
gens qui applaudissent le Hamas mais
espérons que euh l'émotion n'arrive pas
à déboucher sur des actions est-ce qu'on
est aujourd'hui dans une phase de
reprise de de l'activité djihadiste euh
elle n'a jamais cessé euh cette activité
euh les radicalisés le sont maintenant à
travers Internet ils le sont euh par les
réseaux sociaux ils le sont euh voilà
c'est c'est c'est un nouveau phénomène
qui est arrivé on recense à peu près
17000 fichiers S pour radicalisation
islamiste en France donc je ne peux pas
dire que la sécurité totale est assurée
il peut y avoir une sécurité relative
nous avons vu ce qui s'est passé à ras à
Crépol le le couteau a remplacé la
kalashnikov et ça c'est un c'est une
arme facile et à la portée de tout le
monde est-ce qu'avec estce qu'avec
l'attentat de ce samedi vous diriez que
l'État islamique veut se réinstaller
activement et durablement en France je
ne crois pas qu'il y a une une centrale
de l'État islamiste ou de la l'idéologie
en revanche il y a des individus qui se
sont accrochés à cette idéologie
islamiste radicale qui qui veulent eux
passer à l'action pour honorer un
certain engagement c'est plus
une aujourd'hui il y a plus de
centralité qui commande depuis une base
secrète quelque part en Afghanistan en
Syrie ou en Irak des actions
importante comme nous avons connu au
Bataclan il y a quelques années donc il
peut y avoir des des des volonté
solitaire
individuelle d'aller à l'attaque sans
avoir avoir reçu des instructions d'une
centrale installée à l'étranger qui n'a
plus les moyens aujourd'hui l'État
islamique il a pas les moyens de
télégiter des atom non non non
le les islamistes d'Afghanistan ne
peuvent plus se projeter daesh en Irak
et en Syrie a été démelé même s'il y a
des cellules qui continuent à agir
autant dans le désert syrien que qu'en
Irak on va parler de ce qui se passe en
Israël et et à Gaza et et ce weekend
Emmanuel Macron espérait réunir les
dirigeants des pays arabes les plus
concernés par le conflit mais cette
rencontre n'a pas eu lieu est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron s'est mis à dos les
pays arabes par ces positions qui sont
jugées pro
Israël le président de la République a
eu plusieurs déclarations euh qui qui
ont manqué un peu de cohérence d'abord
la coalition
antihamas à l'instar de la coalition
anti daesh n'était pas la bienvenue elle
a été très mal perçue par les pays
arabes d'autant plus que le Hamas a un
agenda nationaliste il revendique un
état il revendique une place sur la
géographie
israélo-palestinienne alors que daesh
c'était une idéologie conquérante et
destructrice donc il y a rien à voir
après le président pour corriger le tir
il a fâché Israël en parlant de cesser
le feu immédiat et puis il en a rajouté
une couche récemment il y a 2 jours dans
le golfe bref on va revenir sur cette
mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est encore
un interlocuteur pour les pays arabes
Emmanuel Macron ou est-ce que avec avec
ce qui s'est passé depuis le 7 octobre
et ses positions il s'est discrédité je
dirais que la parole présidentielle
n'imprime plus dans la région elle est
contradictoire on sait plus où la situé
le en même temps ne ne fonctionne pas je
pense que on attend du président de la
République une vision un plan de paix
qui qui qui soit juste et qui intègre
les deux belligérant dans une projection
de paix régionale au Levant alors vous
l'avez dit Emmanuel Macron a une phrase
ce weekend il a dit la destruction
totale du Hamas est-ce que quelqu'un
pense que c'est possible si c'est ça la
guerre dura 10 ans comment vous
expliquez ce changement ton de la part
du président écoutez demander au
porte-parole de la présidence de
d'interpréter ce ce discours il est vrai
que quelque part
l'idéologie les revendications
nationales ne meurent pas euh voilà ça
fait 75 ans que les Palestiniens ont une
revendication territorial ils ont
accepté y compris d'avoir un état
désarmé au côté d'Israël ça a été répété
il y a 10 jours par le président
égyptien cicii ça avait été évoqué par
le président de l'Autorité palestinenne
en 2018 en disant même mes policiers je
ne veux pas qu'il porte de pistolet donc
les les Palestiniens sont prêts à
rassurer Israël en s'installant à côté
d'Israël sur une portion du territoire
alors que côté israélien on voit les les
messianiques au gouvernement actuel
vouloir pousser les Palestiniens de Gaza
en Égypte et les palestiens du SIS
Jordanie en Jordanie en disant que la
Jordanie c'est la future Palestine sur
le fond cette guerre qui peut durer 10
ans si l'objectif c'était de détruire
complètement le Hamas Emmanuel Macron a
raison d'abord 10 ans c'est extrêmement
long c'est une décenie c'estd Israël
aujourd'hui a mobilisé toutes ses forces
actives il y a
370000 euh appelés réservistes qui sont
au front alors que les usines ne
fonctionnent pas que le tourisme est à
l'arrêt que l'hôtellerie il y a sur la
frontière du Liban 60000 israéliens qui
sont en dehors de chez eux qui sont
hébergés à l'hôtel il y a presque autant
côté Gaza le pays ne peut pas tourner 10
an comme ça la Banque d'Israël a
emprunté 6 milliards de dollars il y a 2
semaines pour combler ce manque de
d'entrée de de dev donc disons c'est
impensable Israël n'a pas non plus
l'éternité auprès des États-Unis ils ont
ils ont peut-être quelques semaines pour
en finir avec cette guerre mais en finir
dans l'expression dans la conception
israélienne ça veut dire pousser les
Gazaouis du nord vers le sud et puis une
fois qu'ils sont dans le sud les pousser
vers l'Égypte donc ce qu'on voit ce ce à
quoi nous assistons aujourd'hui c'est
euh de faire une batue de palestinien en
quelque sorte de les pousser vers le
Sinaï et si l'Égypte n'en veut plus et
bien qu'ils aillent en Europe il y a une
ministre israélienne en exercice qui a
dit l'Europe a la tradition de recevoir
tous les réfugiés du monde et bien
qu'elle accueille les Palestiniens donc
c'est poussé les Palestiniens hors du
territoire pour que la question
territoriale ne se pose plus c'est ça le
plan de Benjamin netanyah c'est c'est
surtout le plan de ces ministres
messianiques smotrich et bengvir
ministre de de des finances et d'une
partie de la défense et ministre de la
police donc de l'intérieur ce sont les
messianiques au sein du gouvernement qui
ne veulent pas voir de palestinien entre
le Jourdain et la Méditerranée et donc
ils ont ils ont ils ont conçu ceci c'est
c'est une ancienne idée mais ils l'ont
ils l'ont mise en app ication et
aujourd'hui l'attaque terroriste du 7
octobre leur a permis de passer aux acte
et de concrétiser cette cette promesse
mais c'est possible ça que cette
promesse soit tenue en tout cas ce que
nous voyons aujourd'hui à Gaza c'est
quoi c'est l'exode du nord vers le sud
et puis une fois qu'ils sont dans le sud
et bombardés ils vont forcément franchir
la frontière au risque que l'Égypte se
fâche vraiment et dise j'annule les
accords de comp David je peux pas
supporter cela et les Égyptiens peuvent
dire à leur gouverneur à leur
gouvernement vous avez dépensé des
milliards pour acheter des armes à quoi
ça serent ces armes si vous pouvez même
pas passer du carburant de la farine de
l'eau à Gaza si vous n'êtes pas capable
de soutenir les Gazaouis qui sont des
frères bombardés à quoi ça sert toute
tout cet arsenal vous pensez que
l'Égypte peut le faire non euh je ne
pense pas que l'Égypte peut passer à la
guerre mais en revanche sous la pression
de l'opinion publique elle peut annuler
ou geler les accords de Camp David ce
qui serait vraiment une révolution et
surtout une un grand succès pour l'Iran
parce que l'Iran a voulu détruire une
cinquantaine d'années de paix entre une
dizaine de pays arabes et Israël est-ce
que ça peut nuire à Israël parce que au
début Israël disait au au au palestinien
de se déplacer vers le sud disant
vouloir protéger les populations civiles
aujourd'hui on voit qu' Israël Bombard
également le sud de Gaza est-ce que ça
peut lui nuire à Israël et dans son
image et vis-à-vis du soutien de
l'opinion internationale je crois que
l'opinion internationale qui a soutenu
Israël de façon très ferme le 7 octobre
quand la la la l'offensive a commencé
sur Gaza ce soutien s'est effrité au
point qu'aujourd'hui on voit les
opinions publiques se retourner contre
Israël parce que 700 morts en 2 jours à
Gaza depuis la reprise des des bomb
ement indiscriminé vous avez des a des
scènes il y a des il y a des centaines
de millions de personnes qui regardent
en direct ce qui se passe à Gaza à
travers aljazira et et autres chaînes
panarabes et et et puis les télévisions
du monde entier reprennent ces images il
y a des images insupportables
insoutenables donc cette
violence contre des civils ne peut pas
attirer la la comment dirais la Simp
h par rapport au Palestiniens la la
trêve a pris fin vendredi matin il y a
des négociations qui ont tenté de se
poursuivre fen puis finalement les
négociateurs ont quitté le Qatar pour
vous c'est c'est aujourd'hui ces
négociations sont dans une impasse
totale aujourd'hui il y a un arrêt des
négociations euh il y a à vrai dire le
seul qui va pouvoir infléchir la
situation ce sont les États-Unis
c'est-à-dire les États-Unis protègent
Israël et lui passe
euh en quelque sorte tous ces caprices
au lieu que les Américains disent à
Israël on vous protège mais voilà le
prix il va falloir accepter de donner
aux Isral aux Palestiniens un morceau de
territoire desés armées et garantir le
votre sécurité à vous deux et bien les
capric d'Israël sont euh acceptés admis
à demi-mot par les États-Unis qui euh ne
conditionnent pas leur soutien militaire
et leur aide économique donc la clé la
principale clé de la solution se trouve
aux États-Unis mais juste sur la fin de
la trêve pour vous c'est Israël qui est
responsable de la fin des négociations
oou les torss sont partagés en
l'occurrence il y a eu un problème
d'interprétation est-ce que les femmes
soldates sont des femmes seulement ou
bien des soldates femmes pour le Hamas
ce sont des soldates et pour Israël ce
sont des femmes pour la libération des
otages et le prix de de la Libération
d'un soldat ou d'un officier ou d'un
général n'est pas un contre trois c'est
l'échange doit être beaucoup plus élevé
donc de ce fait il y a eu euh un
problème d'interprétation de la trêve et
de toutes les façons Israël n'allait pas
pouvoir en rester là Israël était en
première division la puissance
dissuasive de du Moyen-Orient tout le
monde respectait tout le monde craignait
Israël et sa colère éventuelle
aujourd'hui après le 7 octobre Israël
est tombé à la 3è division et cette
colère israélienne cette revanche en
quelque sorte c'est pour rétablir
euh sa sa sa dissuasion et pour dire
qu'elle est extrêmement puissante et
qu'elle a beaucoup de force et que ceux
qui s'attaquent à Israël peuvent être
rayés de la carte c'est ce qui se passe
à Gaza mais est-ce que l'attaque qui a
eu lieu à Jérusalem alors que la trêve
était encore en coursin attaque
revendiquée par le Hamas ça a joué ça
dans la fin de cette trêve le lendemain
je ne crois pas il y a une comment
dirais-je il y a pas de jonction entre
entre la sisjordanie et Gaza il y a une
logique autonome en sisjordanie tous les
jours toutes les nuits il y a des
incursions israéliennes la le jour
d'avant il y a eu quatre morts à génine
dont deux garçonnés de 8 et 15 ans qui
ont été tirés par les snipers de l'armée
israélienne donc le lendemain des des
des les Palestiniens ont voulu se venger
et c'est c'est l'avant d'État qui s'est
installé entre les les colons en
sis-jordanie et les Palestiniens fa sur
les otages oui pour revenir une seconde
sur les otages ce sont toujours c'est
toujours la libérationotage c'est
toujours quelque chose très positif de
très suivi au niveau mondial et est-ce
que fondamentalement ça change la
donne il fallait arrêter la guerre
d'autant plus que les palestinens
étaient disposés à libérer des otages
donc ils ont commencé par les enfants
les les femmes les vieux à un moment
donné Israël se préparait le Hamas aussi
pour la reprise des combats donc
aujourd'hui ce qui reste comme otage
c'est à peu près 140 personnes dont
beaucoup de militaire femme ou homme et
probablement des des officiers
supérieurs dont un général au moins donc
l'échange ne va plus être de 1 contre 3
comme la première tranche mais là les
les les Palestiniens réclament la le
blanchiment entre guillemets des prisons
israéliennes c'estàdire les 5000
prisonniers Palestiniens doivent être
relâchés en même temps que les 140
prisonniers israéliens plus les 3000 qui
ont été arrêtés administrativement
depuis le 7 octobre en
6-jordanie qui est qui est sorti gagnant
pardon pour l'expression mais de ces 7
jours de trêve est-ce que le Hamas est
sorti renforcé euh les 7 jours de trêve
ont permis la libération de 80 personnes
d'un côté et trois fois plus de l'autre
les deux se sont préparés euh pour la le
round suivant et puis euh voilà c'était
une une pause qui était destinée à la
reprise des combats on voyait pas
vraiment Israël s'arrêtait là en en
négociant le blanchiment des prisons euh
israélienne de en libérant tous les
Palestiniens qui qui sont enfermés donc
voilà c'était indispensable pour les
deux de reprendre le combat mais
l'initiative revient je pense à Israël
euh il y a plusieurs pays on en a parlé
plusieurs pays de la région qui
manifestent leur crainte de voir un
embrasement général si Israël va trop
loin est-ce que la crainte est justifiée
oui tout à fait je je vous ai dit que
par rapport à l'Égypte la pression
populaire monte et que à un moment donné
peut-être que le régime décidera de
geler ou d'annuler les accords de Camp
David avec toutes leur implication parce
que la clé de voûte de la paix israelllo
arabe a été euh située à compte David
c'est dire l'accord
israéloégyptien qui a été suivi après
par Oslo par wad Araba avec la Jordanie
puis par les accord d'Abraham bref il y
avait une dynamique de paix de
normalisation
qui a nié négligé oublié le droit des
Palestiniens maintenant c'est l'Iran qui
a remis la cause palestinienne au centre
du jeu et c'est le Hamas qui a ramené la
centralité de la question palestinienne
au risque d'une implosion globale dans
la région et pour Emmanuel Macron il
faut préparer le retour de l'Autorité
palestinienne dans la bande de Gaza
est-ce que pour vous c'est possible mais
il y a pas d'autorité palestinienne il y
a un grabataire à sa tête et c'est une
autorité qui collabore avec Israël qui
n'est plus reconnu par les siens et euh
voilà la collaboration il y a des
services rendus et et donc ça ne
représente plus les Palestiniens en
revanche dans les prisons d'Israël il y
a Marwan bargousi qui qui est un
euh une personnalité respectée et qui
peut demain avec le crédit qu'il a euh
représenter la cause palestinienne tout
en étant un homme raisonnable et un
homme logique donc lui peut reprendre
cette Autorité palestinienne il a le
respect il a la légitimité ça fait 21
ans qu'il est en prison vous avez deux
questions pour terminer fa oui
absolument rappelons que vous êtes
libanais ce pays qui est généralement
victime collatérale dans cette dans
cette région du dans cette région du
monde deux questions qui dirige
réellement le Liban aujourd'hui et puis
une réaction votre réaction à cette à
cet appel de l'Université d'Harvard il y
a quelques jours a dolarisé je reprends
l'expression totalement l'économie
libanaise alors le Liban est dirigé
depuis téran par les pass d'Arran
c'estàd les les Gardiens de la
révolution en ordonnant je dire en
coordonnant avec le Hezbollah qui est la
le comment dirais-je le gestionnaire
local qui contrôle totalement le pays
ils ont vidé la présidence de la
République il n'y a pas de président
depuis maintenant plus d'un an il ils
détiennent tous les pouvoirs le chef de
gouvernement est à leur botte un
gouvernement démissionnaire qui gère les
affaires courantes ils ont le contrôle
des frontières des ports des aéroports
l'administration bref le gouverneur du
Liban aujourd'hui ça s'appelle le
hzbouah il est téléguidé depuis théran
alors la dollarisation de l'économie
elle est déjà dollarisée euh il faut
dire que la la monnaie libanaise est
devenue une monnaie de singe et qu'elle
n'a plus usage dans le pays il faut
passer à la reconnaître la réalité des
échanges les échanges se passent à
travers les dollars et le Liban est en
agonie le Liban est gouverné au profit
de l'Iran à travers le Hezbollah qui
décide de la paix de la guerre qui
décide de tout et qui crée le vide pour
pouvoir installer son propre pouvoir
quel rôle de la France dans tout
ça est-ce que est-ce que on parlait un
peu des tergiversations d'Emmanuel
Macron et de ses différents propos sur
Israël est-ce qu'il en a été de même
avec le Liban euh il y a eu une
tentative il y a eu une tentative quand
même Emmanuel Macron s'est beaucoup
engagé à l'issue de l'explosion du port
qui a fait plus de 200 morts il est allé
deux fois en moins d'un mois il a
proposé un plan
euh les partenaires les Libanais ont
tergversé ils l'ont amené en B tôt et il
s'est avéré que la France ne connaît pas
suffisamment le Liban alors que les plus
proches collaborateurs du président
étaient ambassadeur au Liban bref euh le
résultat est que le Liban est gouverné
par une sorte de mafia et que la mafia
est plus forte que la raison merci
Antoine Basbous merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous on revoit votre livre le
tsunami arabe c'est chez Fayard merci
d'avoir été notre invité merci la
semaine prochaine des territoires